okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 see what's on people's minds
let's start with our caller from the 603
area code caller from 6 0 3 what's your
name where are you calling from alright
Andy we can barely hear you and please
tell me we're not on speakerphone
no yeah we're not that matter it's
marginally better what's on your mind I
was just wondering what your thoughts of
raising the minimum wage or universal
basic income where you're saying one
versus the other or what are my thoughts
on them independently yeah like one
versus the other because I know Bernie
Sanders supports raising the minimum
wage and then Andrew yang supports ubi
yep I'm for both of them so they're sort
of independent issues one is as we
rethink our relationship to work on the
basis of automation and other economic
changes should we be looking into
providing some kind of base level of
income to everybody in a way that will
be economically stimulative and I
believe that the answer is yes and I
think that there's a lot of really good
proposals for that on the other hand
when we talk about a minimum wage that
should be raised part of the reason that
we shouldn't allow the conversation
about the minimum wage to be ignored
when we talk about ubi is we don't want
ubi to subsidize low wages for employers
employers should be paying living wages
and we don't want to sort of bail them
out and allow them to pay wages that are
lower than those paid in 1968 inflation
adjusted merely because we've put in
place universal basic income so I think
we need to do both okay cool thanks all
right thank you for the call great to
hear from you